Marvel Studios has confirmed that there
is indeed going to be a Thor five and it
has been confirmed that Tao atiti who
directed Thor Ragnarok and Thor love and
thunder will not be returning to helm
Thor 5 so for those who didn't like the
direction of Thor love and thunder Tao
atiti is not coming back plus Chris
Hemsworth himself said that yes he would
love to return as Thor however it would
have to be very different than Thor love
and thunder he doesn't want the tone to
be anything like Thor love and Thunder
so if we are talking the opposite tone
of Thor love and thunder which was
basically very silly we are expecting a
mature serious Vibe for Thor 5 so
serious that Thor might actually die and
if he does this is actually the perfect
opportunity for Marvel Studios to tell a
story about Thor from the comics that I
have been wanting them to tell for a
very long time because this story does
involve the death of Thor now of course
the MCU always differs from the comics
but everything that is set up right now
with the Multiverse Saga and Loki being
the igil tree right now holding
everything together Thor five has the
potential to be an amazing movie and it
could reunite Loki and Thor which I know
we've all been waiting for we can't wait
to see Thor reunite with Loki to see how
far his brother has come since he first
fought him in the first Avengers film
albeit it is a different variant of him
but still you know Thor would be super
proud and thanks to Insider Alex P at
the cosm circus it looks like we know a
little bit about what Thor 5 could
actually be about thanks to a recent
discovery that he has made so let's dive
into this new discovery connected to
Loki in Thor 5 and how it means Thor
might actually die in the film also
announcement I started a separate
Channel where I'm going to be discussing
other topics of Pop Culture outside of
Marvel there's going to be a lot of cool
discussions about a lot of cool topics
so I'd love it if you checked it out and
subscribe to the channel and of course
if you love Marvel subscribe to this
channel so you can stay up to date on
the MCU we're also given away A PS5 and
Xbox series X we'll talk more about that
at the end so Insider Alex Perez from
the cosmic circus.com just released an
article talking about a discovery they
made in Thor love and thunder and how it
ties into the Multiverse Saga and the
upcoming Thor 5 I'm not going to read
the entire article verbatim so I
definitely encourage you to go check out
this article on the site I will link it
in the pin comment down below but in his
article he States as one of the sub
headlines the sacred timeline appears in
Thor love and thunder in the post credit
SC for Thor love and thunder we see
Natalie Portman's Jane Foster AKA The
Mighty Thor appear in Valhalla she is
greeted by heimel he thanks her for
protecting his son throughout the movie
and he welcomes her to Valhalla the
Asgardian afterlife Alex points out that
this scene may seem pretty
straightforward however after he further
inspected it holds what appears to be a
massive clue that carries many
implications moving forward not only for
Thor and the Thor franchise but the MCU
overall and specifically the Multiverse
Saga that we are in right now Alex pess
States just as the scene starts if you
pause and look Beyond the Horizon and
Towards the Sky you'll notice the
unwoven threads of the Multiverse in the
background the appearance of these
timelines implies several things about
vahalla and serves as a stepping point
for new theories down the line and
here's the big part he states that their
sources confirmed that part of the early
ideas of the forthcoming Thor 5 film
involve Valhalla as one of the upcoming
locations exploring another aspect of
Norse mythology and if you take a look
at the pictures right here you can
certainly see in the background it does
indeed seem to be the sacred timeline
with timelines branching out he then
goes on to talk about how we could
probably infer that Valhalla does exist
outside of the known Multiverse much
like other places in the MCU do as well
like the quantum realm the duat and the
field of reads and the ancestral plane
from wakanda so since the cosmic
circuses sources confirmed that Valhalla
is going to be one of the major upcoming
locations of Thor 5 and they are going
to explore this other aspect of Norse
mythology in the movie one could assume
that Thor might end up in Valhalla and
if that is the case that means that Thor
has to die because as far as we know
that's the only way to get to Valhalla
now this is going to sound rather weird
but I have always wanted Thor to die in
the MCU because I've always wanted him
to become Rune King Thor I've mentioned
this over the years and a few videos
I've done how I thought that run King
Thor would be amazing but is probably
too op to have in the MCU however now I
think it might be the perfect
opportunity to bring him in when you
consider how strong the Council of kings
are or if the beyonder is going to be
the main villain if you think about how
strong the beyonder is we definitely
need kind of a cosmic entity Thor and
Thor disassembled in the comics we see
Thor return to Asgard to save his home
from Ragnarok which is being led by Loki
when he gets there most of his home and
his people have been taken out already
and there's only a few people left like
his brother baldder the brave Valkyrie
and some close allies so he defeats
finis and durac and vanaheim and then he
encounters the spirit of a boy who
offers him the chance to gain a
tremendous power however this comes at a
tremendous cost the ghost reveals that
he can give him Odin's Powers so Thor
can become an even greater God the young
boy Spirit further tells him that he can
become the all father leading Thor to
pluck both of his eyes out and drop them
in the well of mimir then after drinking
some of the water from the well Thor is
able to look and see into the past and
he learns of Ragnarok however he learns
that in order to complete his quest and
gain the Odin power he will need to die
and be reborn and that is exactly what
he does and Thor ends up in Hell
tormented by Hela but then he gets
rescued by Odin's Spirit then he learns
about these entities called those who
sit above o in Shadow and they feed off
of the Endless cycle of Ragnarok and
that's where Thor realizes that he needs
to stop the cycle of death and rebirth
for good and that's exactly what he does
he returns as run King Thor he defeats
basically everybody however the igdrasil
tree fails and Ragnarok occurs and
everything is destroyed then Thor
basically stands alone as an eternity
like being and begins his Slumber of the
Gods basically Thor sacrifices himself
to save his people this version of Thor
is by far one of the most powerful
versions of Thor to ever exist he
essentially becomes a cosmic entity and
I think that is where we could be
heading in the MCU especially if you
consider that Loki is essentially the
osil tree right now and since the end of
Loki season 2 since we saw Loki become
the osol tree insiders have been stating
that Loki and Thor are going to reunite
again and Loki will indeed be in
Avengers Secret Wars plus we have
reports of the soft reboot coming after
Secret Wars and if we think about how
everything is going to happen in secret
Wars the Multiverse is essentially going
to have to be destroyed which means Loki
is not going to be holding down the
Multiverse anymore So eventually Loki
will kind of be free of being the osil
tree so what I believe could happen in
Thor 5 is that Thor could go up against
Hercules and he could lose and he might
actually die and whether he chooses to
or doesn't choose to one way or another
it looks like he's going to end up inol
Hala and from there that's really where
a bigger purpose for Thor comes into
play that's probably where he's going to
notice the sacred timeline and really
the Multiverse and they could even
realize that it's Loki that is holding
everything together in Norse mythology
those who were in Valhalla were
basically on standby for Ragnarok now
obviously since we have had Thor
Ragnarok in the MCU Ragnarok in the MCU
is very different than the Norse
mythology Ragnarok but Alex Perez in
this article makes a very good point
stating that r Ragnarok in the MCU could
basically be the multiversal war and the
Multiverse falling apart so the
Multiverse being destroyed or Ragnarok
could be where Thor has to step in now
as an even greater being and ascended as
guardian and I also think this would be
a great way to kind of move past the old
plot that was set up in Thor love and
thunder while also keeping some of the
major key aspects and important aspects
of that film like Valhalla but as far as
the Zeus and Hercules thing goes I think
it's going to be really cool to see
Hercules and Thor fight each other but
they can move past that plot because a
lot of people thought that it was kind
of tacky the gods weren't really
depicted how a lot of people thought
they were going to be depicted plus Thor
if he dies and goes to Valhalla will
most likely see Odin and Jane Foster and
his mother and the Warriors 3 it'll be a
really cool reunion if this indeed does
happen in Thor 5 and it would definitely
make Thor have a much greater cause in
the MCU and if you especially consider
the fact that Chris Hemsworth is most
likely done playing Thor after Avengers
Secret Wars it would be really nice to
see his character Thor have an extremely
important role to play in Avengers
Secret Wars with Thor 5 leading up to it
connecting him and Loki together let's
face it there are going to be a ton of
different characters in Avengers Secret
Wars and there's a lot of characters in
the MCU right now just in general so it
would be nice to see Thor kind of shine
above and beyond as an OG character of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so that's
what we've learned about Thor 5 so far
and those are my thoughts about what
Marvel could possibly do to introduce a
super extremely powerful version of Thor
who is also a lot more mature and a lot
more serious I mean if you wanted a more
serious story for Thor 5 him plucking
his eyes out and dying that's pretty
serious but let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video And
subscribe and if you subscribe and leave
a comment you're automatically entered
in our giveaway for a chance to win a
PS5 and Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
the winner gets to pick one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof